ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень», мене звати John Watrous, я є технічним
директором з освіти в IBM Quantum. Це восьмий урок серії і останній урок у
другому розділі серії, присвяченому квантовим алгоритмам. Ми говорили про запитну модель обчислень, включно з квантовими
алгоритмами, які пропонують доведені переваги над класичними алгоритмами в цій моделі. Ми обговорили основоположні концепції, пов'язані з
квантовими алгоритмами та тим, як ми можемо вимірювати обчислювальні витрати, а на попередньому уроці ми обговорили оцінювання фази та алгоритм Шора.
На цьому уроці ми розглянемо алгоритм Гровера, який забезпечує квадратичну перевагу квантових обчислень над
класичними алгоритмами для так званих задач неструктурованого пошуку, які я опишу, щойно ми перейдемо до
уроку. Усе це — основоположні теми, що стосуються квантових алгоритмів. Існують й інші квантові
алгоритми, а також загальні парадигми, що об'єднують різні квантові алгоритми та квантові алгоритмічні техніки, і
якщо тобі цікаво, я раджу завітати до Quantum Algorithm Zoo, який класифікує відомі квантові алгоритми та містить багато посилань
на оригінальні дослідницькі роботи, що сприяли їхньому розвитку. Однак у цій серії
ми зосередимося лише на основах, і починаючи з наступного уроку перейдемо до нової теми. Але
спочатку поговоримо про алгоритм Гровера. Ось огляд уроку: ми почнемо з короткого обговорення
обчислювальної задачі, яку ми розглядатимемо, — неструктурованого пошуку. Інтуїтивно кажучи, можна
думати про задачу неструктурованого пошуку як про пошук серед набору елементів, які не відсортовані та не впорядковані корисним
чином. Потім ми обговоримо алгоритм Гровера — квантовий алгоритм, який пропонує квадратичну перевагу над
класичними алгоритмами, і незабаром ми точно з'ясуємо, що це означає. Дуже загальний опис того,
як працює цей алгоритм: спочатку є крок ініціалізації, а потім операція, яку я називатиму
операцією Гровера, ітерується певну кількість разів, після чого виконується вимірювання, що виявляє кандидата
на розв'язок задачі пошуку. Я поясню, що таке операція Гровера і як її можна
реалізувати на квантовому комп'ютері, а потім проведемо аналіз цієї операції, щоб краще зрозуміти, що вона робить і чому вона корисна для
пошуку. Третя частина уроку стосується кількості ітерацій
в алгоритмі Гровера, або, інакше кажучи, кількості застосувань операції Гровера, якщо ми прагнемо
максимізувати ймовірність того, що алгоритм успішно знайде те, що ми шукаємо, одночасно мінімізуючи його
витрати. Почнемо з задачі унікального пошуку — окремого випадку, в якому існує рівно один розв'язок нашої
задачі пошуку, а потім розглянемо, що відбувається, коли розв'язків кілька. І насамкінець я завершу
урок кількома короткими зауваженнями про алгоритм Гровера та його узагальнення. Почнімо з
обчислювальної задачі, яку ми будемо розглядати впродовж уроку. Спершу, як ми часто робимо, ми
позначимо двійковий алфавіт через Sigma і використовуватимемо це позначення протягом усього уроку, тому нагадувати
я не буду. Припустимо, що є функція f, яка відображає двійкові рядки деякої довжини n в
двійковий алфавіт. Наше припущення полягає в тому, що ми можемо легко обчислити цю функцію, —
наприклад, можливо, у нас є булева схема для цієї функції, розмір якої є поліноміальним від n. Але це не означає, що це
обов'язково проста функція в будь-якому сенсі, або що ми маємо особливо добре розуміння цієї функції. Наприклад, можливо, у нас є
досить складна та заплутана булева схема для обчислення f, яка дозволяє обчислювати її на різних вхідних рядках, але не обов'язково має
зручну форму, що полегшує нам роботу. Наша мета — знайти розв'язок, під яким ми розуміємо
двійковий рядок довжини n, при якому f обчислюється в одиницю. Загалом це дуже складна
обчислювальна задача, або принаймні ми вважаємо, що вона дуже складна. Зокрема, якщо вхідні дані — це
опис булевої схеми для обчислення функції f, то це так звана NP-повна задача. Один зі способів
формалізувати цю задачу — подати її як задачу запитів, і для цілей цього уроку цілком розумно
розглядати цю задачу виключно в контексті запитної моделі. Але коли ми думаємо про те, де або коли ця
задача може виникнути на практиці, природніше думати про f як обчислювану булевою
схемою. Як ми бачили на уроці шість, ці дві точки зору можна пов'язати через конструкцію, яку ми розглядали: взяти булеву схему і
перетворити її на квантовий circuit для реалізації операції або gate запиту. Але загалом концептуально
вхідними даними задачі є функція f, і ми шукаємо розв'язок, якщо він є. А якщо
розв'язку немає, тобто f виявляється константною нульовою функцією, то правильним результатом є відповідь,
що розв'язків немає. Це задача неструктурованого пошуку в тому сенсі, що в f немає
нічого особливого, що полегшувало б пошук розв'язку. Це не схоже на пошук
у даних, які вже впорядковані або завантажені в якусь структуру даних, що полегшує пошук, і немає жодної обіцянки щодо
функції f, яка могла б нам допомогти. Один зі способів це зрозуміти — уявити, що ми шукаємо певний
номер телефону в телефонній книзі, на відміну від пошуку імені, що набагато простіше, якщо імена
впорядковані за алфавітом. На практиці йдеться не стільки про пошук у даних,
які ми схильні організовувати та зберігати так, щоб полегшити пошук, а радше про пошук
розв'язку складного рівняння, наприклад, або, можливо, пошук комбінації, що відкриває
замок. Зауважимо, що цю задачу доцільно розглядати в контексті запитної моделі незалежно від того, як ми можемо
ставитися до практичної значущості цієї моделі. Звичайно, в реальному житті немає оракулів або «чорних скриньок», але поки ми не
дізнаємося про інше, складні та загадкові булеві схеми — це певною мірою «чорні
скриньки». Тепер подумаймо про алгоритми для розв'язання цієї задачі неструктурованого пошуку, і ми будемо робити це
в запитній моделі заради простоти. Якщо у нас є булева схема для нашої функції, а не «чорна скринька»,
ми все одно можемо запускати на ній запитні алгоритми. Але, звичайно, ми не можемо виключати можливість того, що для цієї задачі буде виявлено якийсь новий алгоритм,
який не ґрунтується на запитах. Але ми не будемо переймалися цією
можливістю. Спочатку трохи позначень: загальна кількість вхідних рядків функції f дорівнює 2 у степені
WEBVTT
маленького n, де маленьке n — довжина вхідних рядків для f. Надалі я позначатиму велике N як це число — 2 у степені
маленького n. Досить поширеною практикою є використання великої літери для позначення числа 2 у степені відповідної малої
літери. Ми будемо багато говорити про велике N, тому це просто зручне
скорочення, яке дозволяє тримати все трохи охайнішим. І знову ж таки, це позначення зберігається
протягом усього уроку. Звичайно, ми можемо розв'язати задачу пошуку класично, просто
перебираючи всі можливі n-бітні рядки в довільному порядку та обчислюючи f для кожного з них.
Якщо ми знайдемо розв'язок у будь-який момент, можемо зупинитися. Але в гіршому випадку нам доведеться обчислити f для кожного
вхідного рядка, тому це вимагає N (тобто велике N)
запитів. Ми могли б вимірювати витрати цього обчислення іншим способом, не лише кількістю запитів, але кількість запитів
відповідає кількості разів, скільки нам потрібно обчислити функцію f, і розумно очікувати, що обчислення f домінуватимуть у витратах
цього обчислення. Це насправді найкраще, що ми можемо зробити з детермінованим алгоритмом,
і знову ж таки, це в контексті запитної моделі. Якщо ми зробили запит для кожного вхідного
рядка, крім одного, і f приймала нульове значення для всіх них до цього моменту, як ми можемо бути впевнені, що останній
рядок не є розв'язком? Відповідь така: ніяк. Тому у найгіршому випадку нам потрібні всі N запитів.
Ми також можемо використовувати випадковість, що може дати деякі незначні покращення, наприклад, зменшити
очікувану кількість запитів, необхідних для знаходження розв'язку, якщо він є, або ми могли б фактично обміняти коректність
на зменшення кількості запитів. Але як би ти це не нарізав, нам все одно знадобиться кількість запитів, лінійна
відносно N. Тож класично нам потрібна лінійна кількість запитів, тобто лінійна
відносно великого N. Алгоритм Гровера — це квантовий алгоритм пошуку, який робить краще. Він вимагає лише O від
квадратного кореня з N запитів. Ці запити виконуються в суперпозиції, тому це не магія, але
це значне покращення порівняно з тим, що можливо класично, і саме це мається на увазі під квадратичною
перевагою. Чи можна перетворити цю квадратичну перевагу квантових обчислень над класичними на реальну перевагу на практиці?
Мабуть, не найближчим часом, але у далекому майбутньому — хто знає. Але навіть якщо
алгоритм Гровера ніколи не призведе до практичної переваги при пошуку, він, проте, є важливою частиною
основи квантових алгоритмів і вартий розуміння. Перш ніж перейти до самого алгоритму Гровера, нам потрібно
коротко поговорити про так звані phase query gate. Багато квантових алгоритмів у запитній моделі природно виражаються
за допомогою phase query gate, і ми побачимо, що алгоритм Гровера є конкретним
прикладом. Почнемо з короткого огляду звичайних query gate. Для функції f того
виду, про який ми говорили, query gate UF визначається на стандартних базисних станах так, як показано на
екрані. Для суперпозицій стандартних базисних станів дія визначається лінійністю. Варто нагадати,
що з булевої схеми для f ми насправді можемо побудувати circuit для цієї операції UF, що обходиться в
лінійний час від розміру булевої схеми. Phase query gate для f, яку ми позначимо
назвою ZF, працює таким чином. Зокрема, цей gate діє на
маленьке n qubit на відміну від маленького n плюс один qubit, і він автоматично «вибиває» значення функції
у фазу, а не XOR-ить вихідне значення до додаткового qubit, як ми маємо для
UF. Тому якщо ми думаємо про те, що відбувається, коли ми використовуємо phase kickback на gate UF,
ми фактично просто реалізуємо ZF gate. Нам потрібен мінус-стан, і це коштує одного
обчислення UF. Але ми дійсно отримуємо мінус-стан назад і можемо використовувати його наступного разу, якщо захочемо, або
можемо просто відкинути його. Отже, це і є phase query gate. Тепер, якщо нам просто
дано phase query gate ZF і це єдиний спосіб доступу до функції f, то ми не можемо
відновити gate UF. Але якщо у нас є контрольована версія ZF, то ми можемо
побудувати gate UF, і це я залишу тобі як
вправу. На додачу до phase query gate для функції f нам також знадобиться phase query gate для n-бітної
функції OR, або, інакше кажучи, функції, яка приймає нульове значення для нульового рядка і в інших випадках
приймає одиницю. Явно те, як zor діє на стандартні базисні стани, показано
тут на екрані. Цей gate не залежить від функції f, тому він не вимагає
жодних запитів. Один зі способів побудувати квантовий circuit, що реалізує цю операцію, — зробити щось
подібне до того, що ми робили для функції f, за винятком того, що ми починаємо з булевої схеми, яка обчислює функцію OR для
n бітів. Тепер, коли у нас є ці gate, ми готові перейти до наступного
розділу. Тепер ми обговоримо алгоритм Гровера, починаючи з опису алгоритму. Ми починаємо з ініціалізації
маленького n qubit, кожного в стані плюс, або, інакше кажучи, ми переводимо ці qubit у рівну суперпозицію всіх
двійкових рядків довжини n. Те, що ми будемо робити, — це фактично спрямовувати стан цих qubit
до розв'язку. Тому інтуїтивно зрозуміло, що ми починаємо з цього стану, оскільки ми ще нічого не знаємо про функцію f.
На цьому етапі кожен рядок однаково може бути розв'язком, що відображається у тому, що ці qubit перебувають у рівній суперпозиції всіх
рядків. Потім ми ітеруємо: ми повторно застосовуємо операцію Гровера, яка є справжнім серцем
алгоритму, і я опишу її за мить. Ми застосовуємо цю операцію загалом T разів, де T — деяке невід'ємне
ціле число. Але це число насправді не вказано самим алгоритмом, нам потрібно якось обрати T. У наступному
розділі ми поговоримо про хороші варіанти вибору T. Але зараз ми можемо думати про цю кількість ітерацій T як
про довільну. І нарешті ми вимірюємо в стандартному базисі, що дає нам
кандидата на розв'язок. Немає гарантії, що це дійсно розв'язок, але якщо ми вдало оберемо T,
ймовірність отримати розв'язок може бути зроблена великою. Ось операція Гровера
WEBVTT
безпосередньо, яку ми назвали G. Це композиція операцій, усіх на N qubit, тому це є N-
qubit операцією. Спочатку у нас є gate ZF, або, інакше кажучи, phase query gate для
вхідної функції f, за яким слідує шар gate Hadamard, а потім zor — phase query gate для функції OR,
і нарешті ще один шар gate Hadamard. Отже, ми бачимо, що одна ітерація у
кроці два може бути реалізована circuit, що має вигляд, показаний тут на екрані. Тут у нас чотири qubit, до речі,
але загалом їх може бути будь-яка кількість. Ключова річ, яку варто відзначити: для реалізації G нам потрібен один запит до f.
Нам потрібен один запит для реалізації ZF, і жодна з інших операцій не залежить від f, тому вони не вимагають жодних запитів. Тому це число T,
яке відповідає кількості застосувань G у кроці два, також відповідає кількості необхідних запитів.
Ось типовий спосіб використання алгоритму Гровера, хоча він точно не єдиний.
Як я вже говорив раніше, перше, що нам потрібно зробити, — обрати T, і ми повернемося до цього в наступному розділі.
Для будь-якого обраного T ми запускаємо алгоритм Гровера для T ітерацій і отримуємо кандидата на розв'язок
x. Немає гарантії, що x дійсно є розв'язком, але ми можемо витратити один додатковий запит на перевірку. Якщо ми знайшли розв'язок, можемо
вивести цей розв'язок і зупинитися. Інакше можемо або спробувати ще раз, можливо з іншим вибором T,
але не обов'язково, або відмовитися і повідомити, що розв'язків немає. Як я вже казав раніше, це
не єдиний спосіб використання алгоритму, але це природний спосіб застосування його до задачі пошуку. Далі ми побачимо, що операція Гровера
насправді робить зі станом N qubit, на які вона діє. Думаймо про наші n qubit як
про один регістр, який я назву Q, просто щоб дати ім'я. Пам'ятаємо, що перше, що ми робимо
в алгоритмі Гровера, — це переводимо Q в рівну суперпозицію всіх n-бітних рядків, що ми робимо, застосовуючи gate Hadamard
до n qubit у стані всіх нулів. Потім ми ітеруємо операцію Гровера G і
вимірюємо. Буде корисно розбити множину всіх n-бітних рядків на дві множини: A0 і
A1. A0 містить усі рядки, для яких f обчислюється в нуль, а A1 містить усі рядки, для яких f
обчислюється в одиницю. Іншими словами, A1 містить усі розв'язки нашої задачі
пошуку, тоді як A0 містить усі «нерозв'язки». Нас особливо
цікавитимуть два квантових стани: один — рівна суперпозиція всіх «нерозв'язків», це ket A0, і
другий — рівна суперпозиція всіх розв'язків, це ket A1. Слід зауважити, що ці визначення мають
сенс лише тоді, коли ці множини непорожні, бо інакше ми підсумовуємо нуль елементів і ділимо на нуль. І у процесі
цього аналізу алгоритму Гровера ми будемо робити це припущення. Ми можемо дуже легко з'ясувати, що
алгоритм Гровера робить, коли f є або константною нульовою, або константною одиничною функцією, розглядаючи їх як окремі випадки. Але я залишу це
для самостійного виконання. Не дивно, що якщо кожен рядок є розв'язком, ми дійсно отримаємо
розв'язок після вимірювання. А якщо розв'язків немає, ми не отримаємо жодного, бо їх немає
в принципі. Але для цілей цього аналізу ми припускаємо, що обидві ці множини непорожні, так щоб ці
визначення двох станів мали сенс. До речі, це досить поширене
позначення: коли у нас є непорожня скінченна множина s, ми можемо написати ket s для позначення рівної суперпозиції над
елементами цієї множини, як ми маємо тут. Тому зберемо ці визначення таким чином і подивимося, як вони пов'язані
з алгоритмом Гровера. Перший крок алгоритму Гровера — крок ініціалізації, який переводить Q в рівну
суперпозицію всіх n-бітних рядків. Просто щоб дати цьому стану легко впізнавану назву, я назву його
ket u, де u скорочено від «uniform» (рівномірний). Для цілей аналізу важливо спочатку зауважити, що
цей рівномірний стан ket u міститься в підпросторі, натягнутому на два вектори ket A0 і ket
A1. Зокрема, якщо ми візьмемо лінійну комбінацію цих двох станів, показану тут на екрані, ми отримаємо ket
u. Тепер ключ до всього аналізу полягає в тому, що стан Q залишається в
цьому двовимірному підпросторі незалежно від того, скільки разів ми застосовуємо операцію Гровера. Тому все зведеться
до того, що відбувається у двовимірному підпросторі. Тепер подивімося, що робить операція Гровера, і зокрема, що вона
робить з векторами у двовимірному підпросторі, натягнутому на ket A0 і ket
A1. Корисно уявити, що G розбитий на дві частини: одна частина — це gate ZF,
а інша — gate zor, розміщений між двома шарами gate
Hadamard. Ось визначення ZF, наведене раніше, і з цього визначення досить просто побачити, що його
дія на наші два стани — рівні суперпозиції «нерозв'язків» і розв'язків — полягає просто в тому, щоб поставити знак мінус
перед ket A1. Ну, а до ket A0 нічого не відбувається, і це все, що нам дійсно потрібно знати
про ZF для цілей цього аналізу. Для другої частини, якою є
gate zor, розміщений між двома шарами gate Hadamard, почнімо з нагадування, як визначено zor. Один зі способів його записати
показано на екрані. Це той самий вираз, що й раніше. А ще один спосіб виразити його через нотацію Дірака
виглядає так. Ти можеш перевірити цей вираз, просто подумавши про те, як операція з
правої частини діє на стандартні базисні стани. Зокрема, вона нічого не робить зі станом всіх нулів, а кожен
інший стандартний базисний стан отримує знак мінус, що узгоджується з визначенням z
or. Тому якщо ми розмістимо цю операцію між двома шарами gate Hadamard, ми отримаємо подібний вираз, за винятком
того, що замість стандартного базисного стану всіх нулів у нас тепер є наша рівна суперпозиція ket u. Це пов'язано з тим, що H у степені tensor
n перетворює стандартний базисний стан l0 на ket u, а також H у степені tensor n є своїм власним спряженим транспонуванням, тому він діє аналогічно
справа на бра, а не на кет. Тепер ми з'ясуємо,
що G робить з нашими двома векторами A0 і A1, використовуючи щойно
встановлені факти. Почнімо спочатку з A0. Підставимо вираз,
отриманий для gate zor, розміщеного між двома шарами gate Hadamard. Далі ми можемо скористатися тим фактом, що ZF нічого не робить
WEBVTT
з ket A0, тому ми можемо прибрати операцію ZF. Тепер, використовуючи опис
ket u, що наведений вище, разом із фактом, що ket A0 і ket A1 є ортогональними одиничними векторами, ми можемо обчислити
добуток цього бра з цим кетом, і ми отримуємо квадратний корінь з кількості «нерозв'язків»,
поділений на N. Ми можемо скористатися цим фактом для обчислення результату, і підставивши наш вираз для ket u та
спростивши, отримаємо кінцевий результат, показаний тут на екрані. Зокрема, зауважимо, що цей
вектор міститься у двовимірному підпросторі, натягнутому на ket A0 і ket A1, як я вже припускав. І
більш того, коефіцієнти виявляються дійсними числами. Завжди перевіряй це у
власному темпі, якщо вирішиш це зробити. Я схильний швидко проходити такі речі у цих відео з
розрахунком на те, що ти зробиш паузу та подумаєш, якщо захочеш. Тому почистімо це так,
щоб зберегти кінцевий результат для подальшого використання. Тепер зробимо подібне для вектора ket
A1. Ми можемо використати той самий вираз G, що й раніше. Цього разу gate ZF вносить
знак мінус, що тут відображено тим, що ми поміняли місцями два члени в операції в
дужках. Потім ми діємо дуже подібним чином, і кінцевий результат аналогічний, за винятком того, що два коефіцієнти
міняються місцями і тепер перед одним із них стоїть знак мінус — так виходить алгебраїчно. І знову ж таки, ти
можеш перевірити це у власному темпі. Зауваж, що знову ми маємо дійсну лінійну комбінацію наших двох векторів ket A0 і
ket A1. Ми також почистимо цей вираз і поставимо кінцевий результат поруч з іншим. Тепер ми можемо побачити, як G
діє на підпросторі, натягнутому на наші два вектори. Один зі способів це зробити — виразити його через матрицю 2x2 M,
показану тут на екрані. Просто щоб пояснити, що ми тут робимо: ми асоціюємо перший рядок і перший
стовпець з ket A0, а другий рядок і стовпець з ket A1. Досі у серії ми
використовували матриці переважно для опису того, як операції діють на стандартні базисні стани. Але широко поширеною практикою є використання матриць
для опису дії лінійних відображень на різні набори векторів, а не лише на стандартні базисні стани. І тут ми говоримо про те, що операція G робить
з векторами ket A0 і ket A1. Ми можемо сказати більше про те, що G робить з векторами у
просторі, натягнутому на ket A0 і ket A1, якщо уважніше подивимося на матрицю M. Зокрема, ми виявимо,
що M є матрицею повороту, тобто її дія на цей двовимірний простір може бути описана як поворот на деякий
фіксований кут. Є кілька способів це побачити. Один полягає в тому, щоб зауважити,
що цю матрицю M можна виразити як квадрат дещо простішої матриці. Це може бути важко помітити, якщо
ми просто дивимося на M, але це не щось, що нам потрібно відкривати самостійно — нам просто потрібно перевірити, що ми можемо зробити, просто
піднісши матрицю праворуч у квадрат. Ще один спосіб записати матрицю праворуч, не включаючи квадрат,
показано на екрані. Це типовий спосіб описати поворот на заданий кут Theta як
матрицю. Точний кут повороту виявляється рівним арксинусу квадратного кореня з кількості
розв'язків, поділеної на N. До речі, оскільки ми бачимо це вперше, зазначимо, що
цей кут дуже важливий і він постійно з'являтиметься, коли ми продовжуватимемо
аналіз. Аргумент арксинуса — це число від 0 до 1. Конкретно, ми
інтерпретуємо арксинус тут як кут від 0 до Pi/2, що дає нам аргумент, коли ми беремо
синус. Отже, це один спосіб думати про матрицю, яку ми підносимо у квадрат, щоб отримати
M. Оскільки підняти матрицю у квадрат — це те саме, що застосувати її двічі, ми бачимо, що M можна альтернативно записати як
поворот не на кут Theta, а на два Theta, бо підносячи у квадрат, ми повертаємо на кут Theta
двічі. Інший спосіб перевірити все це, якщо це корисно, — почати з цього кінцевого виразу M
і скористатися формулами подвійного кута з тригонометрії, щоб отримати початковий вираз
M. Це вираз M, який описує дію G на підпросторі, натягнутому на ket A0 і ket A1, що
буде найбільш корисним надалі. Тепер повернемося до самого алгоритму Гровера. Після
кроку ініціалізації, але до виконання будь-яких застосувань G, стан нашого N-qubit регістра Q — це ket u, тобто
рівна суперпозиція всіх n-бітних рядків. Тут ми маємо той самий вираз ket u через ket A0 і
ket A1, що й раніше. Але тепер, визначивши цей кут Theta, ми бачимо, що
ket u можна також записати як cosine(Theta) * ket A0 плюс sin(Theta) * ket
A1. Для коефіцієнта при ket A1 це очевидно, а для іншого коефіцієнта нам просто потрібно зауважити, що розмір A0 плюс
розмір A1 дорівнює N, і тоді ми можемо отримати його з елементарної тригонометрії. Отже, це стан, з якого ми
починаємо. Перший раз, коли ми застосовуємо G, ми повертаємо на кут 2*Theta, тому загальний кут стає 3*
Theta. Якщо ми знову застосуємо G, кут збільшується до 5*Theta, бо ми фактично повернули на додатковий
кут 2*Theta. І так далі. Після T застосувань G ми можемо представити
стан, що ми отримуємо, як показано на екрані, де кут нашого стану дорівнює (2T + 1) * Theta — це 2*Theta
за кожне застосування G плюс додатковий Theta, бо саме в такому стані ми починали.
Ми також можемо думати про дію операції Гровера в геометричних термінах, і це допомагає пролити трохи світла на те, як
вона працює і чому її ефект — поворот вектора стану регістра Q. Ось головна ідея. Операція Гровера —
це композиція двох частин, які ми вже визначили: одна — ZF, а інша — zor, розміщений між
двома шарами gate Hadamard. Ці дві частини є
відображеннями, і коли ми складаємо два відображення, ми отримуємо поворот. Тому подивімося, як це працює
детальніше. Спочатку зосередимося на ZF і обмежимо нашу увагу
тим самим двовимірним підпростором, про який ми говорили, тобто тим, що натягнутий на ket A0 і ket
A1. Як ми вже спостерігали, дія ZF на цьому просторі досить проста: вона нічого не робить
з ket A0 і ставить знак мінус перед ket A1. Це відображення, і конкретно
WEBVTT
це відображення відносно прямої, паралельної ket A0, яку ми назвемо L1, просто щоб дати ім'я.
Щоб зрозуміти, чому це відображення, корисно намалювати картинку. Ось наші два вектори ket
A0 і ket A1, які є ортогональними одиничними векторами. Ми можемо думати про екран як про множину всіх дійсних
лінійних комбінацій цих двох векторів. Тому коло представляє всі одиничні вектори, коефіцієнти яких при
цих двох векторах є дійсними числами. Ось пряма L1, паралельна ket A0. Якщо ми візьмемо деякий
довільний вектор s на цьому колі, то ефект від застосування ZF — відображення відносно цієї прямої, як показано на
екрані, — просто тому, що ми нічого не робимо з ket A0 і ставимо знак мінус перед ket
A1. У спеціальному випадку, коли s = ket A0, наприклад, нічого не відбувається при цьому відображенні. Коли ж s =
ket A1, відображення переводить нас аж до від'ємного ket A1, що узгоджується з дією ZF. Отже, ZF — це
відображення, яке можна візуалізувати так, як ми маємо тут. Друга частина G — це zor,
розміщений між двома шарами gate Hadamard, — може бути виражена як 2 * ket u * bra u мінус одинична матриця, як ми
вже бачили. І знову ж таки, це відображення, цього разу відносно прямої L2, паралельної ket u, а не ket
A0. Ми можемо візуалізувати цю операцію аналогічно до ZF. Ось вектор ket
u гіпотетично, це пряма L2, паралельна ket u. Знову дія на довільний вектор s — відображення
відносно прямої, якою є L2 у цьому випадку.
І нарешті, як я вже згадував, завжди, коли ми складаємо два відображення, ми отримуємо поворот. Конкретно це
поворот на подвійний кут між прямими відображення. Намалюємо подібну
картинку до тієї, що ми мали раніше. Ось прямі відображення з кутом Theta між
ними. Якщо ми візьмемо деякий довільний вектор s, відобразимо відносно першої прямої L1 і
потім відобразимо відносно другої прямої L2, то чистим ефектом буде поворот вектора s на кут двох Theta.
Це справедливо загалом, і ти можеш перевірити на додаткових прикладах власноруч, щоб переконатися, що це справді так.
Так чи інакше, сподіваюся, це допомагає тобі отримати деяку інтуїцію щодо того, чому операція Гровера має ефект повороту
векторів. Далі ми перейдемо до питання вибору кількості ітерацій T в алгоритмі Гровера.
Почнімо з того, як аналіз, який ми бачили до цього і який розкриває, що робить операція Гровера,
при багаторазовому застосуванні до рівної суперпозиції пов'язаний із задачею, яку ми прагнемо розв'язати, — знайти розв'язок нашої задачі пошуку,
або, іншими словами, будь-який рядок, що міститься в множині A1. Якщо коротко, ми фактично будемо
задавати ціль і потім з'ясовувати, скільки разів потрібно застосувати операцію Гровера, щоб наблизитися до цієї
цілі. Спочатку уявімо, що у нас є будь-який стан, що є лінійною комбінацією наших двох векторів ket A0 і ket
A1. Якщо ми виконаємо вимірювання в стандартному базисі цього стану, ми отримаємо результат у множині A1, тобто
множині розв'язків нашої задачі пошуку, з ймовірністю, рівною квадрату модуля будь-якого коефіцієнта при ket A1. Для
вектора, показаного на екрані, цей коефіцієнт — beta. Це інтуїтивно зрозуміло: якби ми вимірювали стан ket A0,
ми б отримали випадковий «нерозв'язок». А якби ми вимірювали ket A1, ми б отримали випадковий розв'язок. Тому якщо ми вимірюємо цей стан
прямо тут, ми отримаємо випадковий «нерозв'язок» з ймовірністю квадрата модуля alpha і випадковий розв'язок
з ймовірністю квадрата модуля beta. Але ми також можемо просто витратити мить, щоб розібратися. Ось стан, записаний
так, щоб ми могли бачити, які записи цього вектора для стандартних базисних станів. Якщо ми вимірюємо, ось
ймовірності отримати кожен можливий результат. Щоб отримати ймовірність отримати розв'язок, ми підсумовуємо
ймовірності для всіх можливих розв'язків, що дає нам квадрат модуля beta, як
і очікувалося. Тепер ми вже проаналізували, що відбувається, коли ми запускаємо алгоритм Гровера для T ітерацій: ми отримуємо стан,
показаний тут на екрані. Оскільки коефіцієнт при ket A1 є синусом
від (2T + 1)*Theta, де знову ж тут цей дуже важливий кут Theta,
ми побачимо розв'язок з ймовірністю sin²((2T + 1) *
Theta). Ми хочемо зробити цю ймовірність великою, в ідеалі якомога ближчою до одиниці. Тому, повертаючи вектор стану,
ітеруючи G, ми будемо думати про ket A1 як про цільовий стан і намагатимемося
обрати T так, щоб наблизитися до цього стану. При цьому добре пам'ятати, що ми також хочемо
мінімізувати T, бо це кількість запитів, які нам потрібно зробити. Тому, щоб зробити цю
ймовірність близькою до одиниці і мінімізувати T, має сенс намагатися зробити кут нашого вектора стану близьким до Pi/2, бо
це найменший кут, при якому квадрат синуса великий. Тому, по суті, це наша перша можливість зробити ймовірність великою, коли ми повертаємо
вектор стану. Ми не можемо обов'язково точно потрапити в цей кут Pi/2, бо T має
бути цілим числом. Але якщо ми думаємо про це приблизно і розв'язуємо для T так, ніби це нерівність, то бачимо, що в ідеалі
вибір T рівним Pi/(4*Theta) мінус 1/2 має
сенс. Але, звичайно, T має бути невід'ємним цілим числом. Тому ми
беремо найближче ціле число до того, що ми вважаємо ідеальним значенням, а саме підлогу від Pi/(4*
Theta). Взяти підлогу, до речі, просто означає відкинути дробову частину, тобто, інакше кажучи, це найбільше
ціле число, що не перевищує те, від чого ми беремо підлогу. Відповідно до цього виразу, якщо
ідеальне значення опиняється рівно між двома цілими числами, ми округляємо вгору. Але це насправді взагалі не матиме значення для
цілей цього уроку. Тому надалі ми зосереджуватимемося на цьому конкретному виборі
T. Але є ще одне важливе міркування: специфікація T залежить
від кількості розв'язків, бо кут Theta залежить від кількості
розв'язків. Надалі я буду використовувати літеру s для позначення кількості розв'язків, або, іншими словами, розміру
множини A1, просто для зручності. Так чи інакше, суть у тому, що наш
вираз для T — значення, яке, за нашою гіпотезою, повинно бути хорошим, — залежить від Theta, а Theta залежить від s, тобто
WEBVTT
від розміру множини A1. Це не проблема, якщо ми заздалегідь знаємо, скільки розв'язків є. Але
якщо ми заздалегідь не знаємо кількість розв'язків, ми не знаємо Theta, тому не можемо вибрати T таким чином
і нам доведеться робити щось інше. Я повернуся до ситуації, коли ми не знаємо s, трохи пізніше. Але спочатку
зосередимося на ситуації, коли ми знаємо кількість розв'язків, починаючи з унікального пошуку,
де гарантовано є єдиний унікальний розв'язок, який ми шукаємо.
Я згадував задачу унікального пошуку як приклад задачі запитів ще на уроці
п'ять. Вхідні дані — функція f від n бітів до одного біта, існує унікальний n-бітний
рядок, для якого f обчислюється в одиницю, і мета — вивести цей рядок. Отже,
це еквівалентно задачі неструктурованого пошуку, яку ми розглядали, але з обіцянкою, що є рівно один розв'язок. І насправді це
єдина версія задачі пошуку, яку Лав Гровер розглядав у своїй оригінальній роботі 1996 року, що ввела алгоритм Гровера.
Для унікального пошуку s = 1, тому цей важливий кут Theta рівний арксинусу
квадратного кореня з 1/N. Для великих N це значення наближено дорівнює квадратному кореню з 1/N —
це тому, що для все менших і менших кутів синус починає все більше нагадувати тотожну
функцію. Якщо підставити це наближення в наш вибір T, ми бачимо, що T наближено дорівнює підлозі
від Pi/(4 * квадратний корінь з N). Це добре, бо ми на шляху до використання O(квадратний корінь з N)
запитів, хоча на цьому етапі ми ще не дивилися на те, наскільки добре алгоритм
працює. Розглянемо приклад, де велике N = 128, тобто 2^7. Отже,
наша функція f відображає сім бітів в один, і ми припускаємо, що є унікальний розв'язок. Але щоб з'ясувати, наскільки
добре алгоритм працює, нам насправді потрібно лише звернути увагу на кут Theta, який ми можемо обчислити. Він
наближено дорівнює 0.0885 радіана, що трохи більше ніж 5°. Якщо підставити це значення в наш
вираз для T, отримаємо вісім. Тобто ми думаємо про те, що відбувається, коли ми шукаємо унікальний розв'язок серед 128
можливостей, використовуючи вісім запитів. Ми можемо намалювати картинку, щоб проілюструвати, як стан змінюється з
часом у процесі ітерацій операції Гровера. Як і раніше, є стани ket
A0 і ket A1. У цьому конкретному випадку — унікального пошуку — ket A1 — це фактично стандартний базисний стан,
що відповідає унікальному розв'язку, яким би він не був. Ну, а ket A0 — це рівна суперпозиція всіх
рядків, крім унікального розв'язку. Ось рівна суперпозиція над усіма рядками, яку
ми можемо записати як cosine(Theta) * ket A0 плюс sin(Theta) * ket A1. І зрозуміло, що ket A0
і ket u є близькими в цьому випадку, бо, як ми щойно зауважили, ket A0 —
це майже рівна суперпозиція всіх рядків: відсутній лише один рядок, а саме унікальний розв'язок. Застосування G знову повертає на
додатковий 2*Theta. Ось де ми є після двох ітерацій. Ось три, чотири, п'ять, шість, сім і вісім.
Тепер ми бачимо, що ми досить близько до ket A1. Тому якщо ми зупинимося і виміряємо в цей момент, ми, швидше за все, отримаємо
унікальний розв'язок. І насправді в цьому випадку є лише близько половини відсотка шансу, що ми не отримаємо унікальний
розв'язок. З іншого боку, якби ми продовжували застосовувати операцію Гровера більше, ніж рекомендовані вісім разів,
то ймовірність отримати розв'язок знижувалася б і з часом коливалася б, коли стан іде навколо
кола. Тому важливо зупинити ітерації в потрібний момент, якщо ми хочемо успішно
завершити з високою ймовірністю. Подумаймо про ймовірність того, що наш вибір T виявляє унікальний розв'язок, більш загально для різних значень
N. Ми запишемо p(N,1) для позначення ймовірності того, що алгоритм Гровера успішно знаходить унікальний розв'язок
для кожного можливого значення N. Одиниця означає один розв'язок, і ми розширимо це позначення для інших кількостей розв'язків
незабаром. Ось таблиця цих ймовірностей для малих степенів двійки. Вона починається з N=2, і
ймовірність 1/2, що не дуже добре. Але для N=4 ймовірність рівно дорівнює одиниці, тому алгоритм працює
ідеально в цьому випадку. Це чудова вправа, до речі — явно розібрати, як ці два випадки працюють,
особливо випадок N = 4. У цьому випадку ми шукаємо один розв'язок серед чотирьох можливостей,
нам потрібен лише один запит, і це працює ідеально. З ростом N ми бачимо деякі коливання: ймовірності дещо
зростають і спадають. Але виглядає, що вони наближаються до одиниці, і це дійсно так. Можна довести
аналітично, що ймовірність завжди щонайменше 1 - 1/N. Тому це добре.
Алгоритм не є ідеальним, ми не гарантовано отримаємо розв'язок, але це досить ймовірно, особливо для великих
значень N, а також через дуже цікаву аномалію, яка відбувається при N = 4.
Також слід зауважити, що ми завжди можемо запустити весь алгоритм, включаючи вимірювання, стільки разів, скільки захочемо. Якщо будь-який запуск
успішний, ми отримаємо розв'язок. Тому якщо ці ймовірності недостатньо хороші, ми можемо легко їх підвищити, просто повторно запускаючи
алгоритм. Насправді, навіть якби ці ймовірності всі дорівнювали 1/2, наприклад, у нас все одно був би
корисний алгоритм пошуку. Тепер розглянемо, що відбувається, коли є кілька
розв'язків. Почнімо з подібного прикладу до попереднього. Знову N = 128, але цього разу
кількість розв'язків s = 4, а не 1. Знову ми можемо обчислити Theta і T, і
ми отримуємо, що Theta ≈ 0.1777, або трохи більше ніж 10°, а T =
4. Цього разу кут приблизно вдвічі більший, ніж у попередньому прикладі, а T вдвічі менший.
Ми можемо намалювати картинку, як раніше. Ось де ми
починаємо. Ось одна ітерація, дві, три і чотири. Цього разу ми дуже близькі до ket
A1. Ймовірність отримати розв'язок цього разу виявляється більшою за
99.9%. Але якби ми не знали нічого кращого і думали, що є лише один розв'язок, ми б взяли T = 8, як
раніше. Ми б повернули майже до від'ємного ket A0, і це призвело б до дуже малої ймовірності
успіху. Отже, це ще один приклад, що показує: є хороші варіанти T і погані варіанти T. І тут ми бачимо,
WEBVTT
що хороший вибір для s = 1 виявляється дуже поганим для s = 4. Але припускаючи, що ми дійсно знаємо s
заздалегідь і вибираємо T відповідно до нашої специфікації, виявляється, що алгоритм Гровера знайде розв'язок
з ймовірністю щонайменше 1 - s/N, і часто це буде набагато більше. Він також щонайменше s/N, але
це насправді набагато менш цікаво. Більш цікавим є те, що зі зменшенням частки s/N оцінка знизу
ймовірності успіху все більше наближається до одиниці. Тепер, як я вже зауважував кілька
разів, число T відображає не тільки кількість ітерацій операції Гровера, але й кількість
запитів. Тому як це число залежить від s і
N? Почнімо з того факту, що арксинус від x завжди не менший за x, за умови, що x знаходиться між 0 і 1.
Це досить легко показати, якщо ти знаєш ряд Тейлора для арксинуса. Але є й інші способи обґрунтувати це, і ми просто
приймемо це як дане, бо це правда. Це означає, що Theta не менший за квадратний корінь з s/
N, і, відповідно, T не більший за Pi/(4 * квадратний корінь з N /
s). Отже, це навіть краще, ніж O(корінь з N). Чим більше s
відносно N, тим менше запитів нам потрібно зробити. І, в певному сенсі, не дивно, що ця дріб з'являється
таким чином, зважаючи на те, що її обернена величина визначає Theta, а наприкінці кінців Theta — це все, що має значення для
цього аналізу. Як ми щойно бачили, алгоритм Гровера добре працює, коли ми знаємо
заздалегідь кількість розв'язків. Але що, якщо ми не знаємо кількість розв'язків?
Є один досить простий підхід: просто вибрати кількість ітерацій
випадково. Конкретно, вибір T рівномірно випадково між 1 і підлогою від Pi/(4 * корінь з N) виявляється
досить хорошим способом. Верхня межа цього діапазону — приблизно кількість запитів, яку ми б вибрали для унікального пошуку, і насправді
це рівно правильне число в більшості випадків — коли кут Theta найменший, яким він може бути, виключаючи
тривіальний випадок, коли розв'язків немає. Ідея тут така: замість того, щоб ретельно цілитися нашим вектором стану в
ket A1, як ми робили, коли знали кількість розв'язків, ми фактично обертаємо на випадковий кут, ніби даємо
вектору стану випадковий оберт. Якщо раптом є лише один розв'язок, наш випадковий оберт може підштовхнути
вектор стану близько до ket A1, але може й зупинитися лише на півдорозі. А якщо раптом є багато розв'язків, то
наш випадковий оберт міг би потенційно відправити вектор стану навколо кола кілька разів. Тому ми не очікуємо, що це виявить
розв'язок з ймовірністю, близькою до одиниці. Але шанс, що це призведе до розв'язку, якщо він є, виявляється
досить хорошим. Він завжди щонайменше 40%. Насправді, це неочевидно, але так і є.
Це не шокує, бо справді випадковий кут мав би 50% шанс знайти
розв'язок. Але в будь-якому разі 40% — непогано. І пам'ятай, що ми завжди можемо підвищити ймовірність знаходження розв'язку,
повторюючи процес, вибираючи T незалежно кожного разу. Роблячи це, шанси не знайти
розв'язок, якщо він є, спадають експоненційно в залежності від кількості повторень. Тому якщо ми хочемо 99%-вий
шанс знайти розв'язок, ми можемо запустити цей простий підхід 10 разів, знову з T, вибраним незалежно кожного
разу. Природно, якщо ми не знаходимо розв'язку, ми виводимо «розв'язків немає». Якщо розв'язків
немає, ми не знайдемо жодного, і в цьому випадку ми завжди виведемо правильну відповідь «розв'язків немає». Якщо розв'язки є, ми
можемо не знайти жоден і помилково оголосити, що розв'язків немає. Але ймовірність такого можна зробити дуже малою.
Також, як я згадував кілька хвилин тому, це вимагає кількості запитів, або обчислень f, що є O від кореня
з N. Тому, використовуючи алгоритм Гровера, ми все одно можемо розв'язати задачу пошуку з високою ймовірністю за O від кореня з N
запитів, навіть якщо ми заздалегідь не знаємо кількість розв'язків. Існує також більш складний
підхід, що може призвести до зменшення кількості запитів у міру зростання числа розв'язків. Я не буду описувати його
детально, а натомість просто зосереджуся на основній ідеї. Ми починаємо з великого T, рівного
одиниці. Потім запускаємо алгоритм Гровера для випадкової кількості ітерацій, де верхня межа — T. Тобто перший
раз, коли ми доходимо до кроку два, ми запускаємо алгоритм Гровера з однією ітерацією. Але T буде
зростати. Якщо ми знаходимо розв'язок, то виводимо його і зупиняємося. Якщо не знаходимо, збільшуємо T
і пробуємо ще раз. В якийсь момент, до того як T стане занадто великим, ми завершимо процес і
оголосимо, що розв'язків немає. Це та сама основна ідея, що й у простому підході, де ми
фактично даємо вектору стану випадкові оберти. Але тут ми починаємо з легших обертів спочатку, коли T
малий, на випадок, якщо розв'язків багато. Таким чином ми не витрачатимемо запити, змушуючи стан ходити навколо
і навколо кола, надто сильно обертаючи. Але якщо це не спрацює, тобто якщо ми не знаходимо розв'язку, ми пробуємо ще раз,
але обертаємо трохи сильніше, або потенційно трохи сильніше. Щоб це спрацювало, швидкість
збільшення T потрібно вибрати ретельно. Один зі способів змусити це працювати — замінити T стелею від (5/4) * T.
Тобто T збільшується експоненційно, і інтуїтивно ми можемо думати про це як про обертання на 25% сильніше кожного
разу. Для аналізу важливо, що T збільшується саме експоненційно. Чому 5/4, можна запитати? Ну, це
просто число, яке працює. Насправді є діапазон значень, які працюють, але два, наприклад, не працює: подвоєння T
кожен раз — це занадто швидке збільшення, щоб повністю скористатися перевагами легших обертів. Але суть цього більш
складного методу полягає в тому, що він дає ту саму асимптотичну оцінку на кількість необхідних запитів, що й раніше:
O від кореня з N/s. Але нам не потрібно заздалегідь знати кількість розв'язків. До речі,
ми можемо зупинити цей процес, коли T досягне кореня з N. Тому, якщо розв'язків немає, ми дійдемо до цього висновку після O від
кореня з N запитів. І ось як ми можемо вибирати кількість ітерацій в алгоритмі Гровера. На завершення уроку я
зроблю лише кілька коротких зауважень про алгоритм Гровера. По-перше, в рамках запитної моделі
алгоритм Гровера є асимптотично оптимальним. Це означає, що неможливо придумати
запитний алгоритм для розв'язання задачі пошуку або навіть задачі унікального пошуку зокрема, який використовував би асимптотично
WEBVTT
менше, ніж O(корінь з N) запитів у найгіршому випадку. Це те, що можна довести строго,
і насправді є кілька відомих доведень цього факту. Цікаво, що це було відомо навіть
до того, як було відкрито алгоритм Гровера. Алгоритм Гровера відповідав вже відомій нижній оцінці на кількість
необхідних запитів. Час від часу люди дійсно пропонують підходи, які, на їхню думку, є асимптотично
кращими за алгоритм Гровера. Але завжди або є помилка, або припущення про функцію f і
те, як до неї можна звернутися, або інша проблемна проблема, що робить твердження некоректним. Якщо ти правильно працюєш
у рамках запитної моделі, ти не можеш перевершити алгоритм Гровера для неструктурованого пошуку. По-друге, алгоритм Гровера є
досить широко застосовним у тому сенсі, що квадратне прискорення, яке алгоритм Гровера пропонує для задачі неструктурованого пошуку, можна
отримати у різних налаштуваннях. Наприклад, іноді можна використовувати алгоритм Гровера
поверх іншого алгоритму, щоб отримати квадратичне покращення понад його продуктивність. Алгоритм Гровера також
досить часто використовується як підпрограма в інших квантових алгоритмах. Ось лише один простий приклад: ми
можемо використати алгоритм Гровера, щоб отримати квадратичну перевагу над класичними алгоритмами для задачі мінімуму, яку я згадував на
уроці п'ять. І нарешті, техніка, використана в алгоритмі Гровера, де два
відображення складаються і ітеруються для повороту квантового вектора стану, може бути узагальнена досить
суттєвим чином. Прикладом є техніка, відома як amplitude amplification, де процес,
що узагальнює алгоритм Гровера, може бути застосований до іншого квантового алгоритму, щоб по суті підвищити ймовірність його успіху квадратично швидше, ніж
це було б можливо класично. Ця техніка має широке застосування в квантових алгоритмах. Тому може бути правдою, що
алгоритм Гровера, ймовірно, не призведе до практичної квантової переваги найближчим часом, якщо взагалі коли-небудь. Але алгоритм Гровера
без сумніву є фундаментально важливим і широко застосовним квантовим алгоритмом, і він є представником більш загальної техніки, що має багато
застосувань. І на цьому цей урок і цей розділ серії, присвячений квантовим
алгоритмам, завершено. Ми обговорили запитну модель і те, як ми можемо пов'язати її зі стандартнішою моделлю обчислень, разом із
деякими іншими основоположними концепціями щодо вимірювання обчислювальних витрат. Потім ми розглянули оцінювання фази,
факторизацію і, нарешті, алгоритм Гровера. Як я вже запропонував,
є ще багато чого дізнатися про квантові алгоритми. Але в цій серії ми перейдемо до іншої теми в наступному розділі. Зокрема, ми подивимося на
загальне формулювання квантової інформації, де квантові стани представлені матрицями певного
вигляду, відомими як матриці густини. Як ми побачимо, це формулювання виявляється дуже корисним і справді
необхідним для розуміння деяких аспектів квантової інформації. Воно також виявляється досить красивим із
математичної точки зору. Тому сподіваюся, ти приєднаєшся до мене для третього розділу. До побачення,
до наступного разу.